you know people have said the guys will
relate to a movie called bridesmaids
turns out the world can still surprise
you
[Music]
bridesmaids so bridesmaids is pretty
much exactly what it sounds like an SNL
chicks getting married so all of her
bridesmaids are planning her wedding
headed up by the chick from macGruber
who's really funny I'm a funny chick
comedian awesome I guess she's also one
of the writers of the movie so there you
go
now people are comparing this movie to
hangover I don't think that's fairest
not really the same movie is hangover
it's not like these bridesmaids go like
Vegas or anything like that for a
bachelorette party and then shenanigans
ensue it's not like that all the stuff
that happens happens in the course of
planning this wedding and anyone who's
ever known someone who's gotten married
knows that there's a lot of stuff that
can happen and I got to say Rose burns
in the movie and she's a really diverse
actress usually when I've seen her she's
like this really timid really cute sweet
chick and this one she's a total like
former model trophy wife when I first
saw her I was like oh she's all pretty
and hot about three minutes later I was
like I want to kick that chick in the
teeth yeah it turns out she's the bride
two B's best friend and chick from
macGruber is like her longtime best
friend and they're both stubborn they're
both always right and they're both
really competitive makes for some funny
stuff now what I like most about the
movie the way that everyone can relate
to this movie is that the dialogues just
really funny because normal people
really talk like this if you've ever had
a friend in your life you can relate to
bridesmaids and yeah guys I'm talking to
you out there leave it or not it's like
a comedic Lee idealistically realistic
way of talking and I thought all the
bridesmaids were pretty funny too I mean
Aaron from the office is in it and she
plays pretty much Aaron from the office
but the bridesmaid I liked most was the
fat chick or the heavy chick whatever I
want to offend people but she is the fat
chick she would laugh at that cuz she's
hilarious there's something off about
that chick she's kind of like Gary Busey
I was watching the movie I was like
there's something Gary Busey is sure
about that chick she had me right there
and one thing we can always learn from
this movie is that when dudes and chicks
you know do the whole dude and chick
thing dudes and chicks start acting
stupid life lessons from bridesmaids so
the rumors are true both dudes and
chicks alike and both relate to and
laugh with bridesmaids rare that you can
go to like a date night and not have to
like fake a phone call and leave the
theater for you know 45 minutes and the
movie has like a lot of heart too and I
was leaving the theater this one dude
was like a little more dramatic than I
expected I honestly replied yeah it's
called a good movie so props to
bridesmaids for having come
heart so what's better than a good time
no alcohol required I gotta say I would
buy it on blu-ray now if you wait too
long everyone's gonna hail bridesmaids
it's like this awesome summer comedy
like the best one in years and it's
gonna be overhyped so don't wait too
long to watch it so if you're a dude and
you saw bridesmaids and you like
bridesmaids don't worry you're among
friends here and if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]